Trascrizione: Chiara Carnevali
Revisore: Martina Abrami
Faccio un lavoro che impegna
il mio fisico, il mio intelletto,
ma anche il mio cuore.
È un lavoro che richiede
una ricerca della perfezione
ed essendo perfezionista,
non mi arrendo mai.
Se ci penso bene, mi sfinisce.
Incontro tensioni interpersonali,
stress, ansia da prestazione,
sempre.
La voglia di nascondermi sotto le coperte
alla fine della giornata è molto grande
perché spesso le cose che pianifico
non vanno come vorrei.
E dunque, spesso,
mi ritrovo senza motivazione
e rimprovero, forse, quasi,
la mia scelta professionale.
Il mio lavoro richiede una vastissima
conoscenza del proprio campo,
del proprio ambiente.
È un ambiente che cambia in continuazione,
è imprevedibile, ma è bellissimo.
Infatti, il mio lavoro
richiede una passione
e una voglia di cambiare le cose
senza tregua.
Io coltivo carote.
Ovviamente, non solo.
Sono socia dell’azienda agricola Foradori.
Noi siamo un’azienda
a conduzione familiare
qui in piana, a Mezzolombardo.
Siamo quattro soci:
tre fratelli e mia mamma.
Potete capire una gran parte
dello sfinimento nervoso
dovuto anche alle dinamiche
familiari in azienda.
Ne sanno qualcosa i nostri dipendenti.
Chiunque entra respira un’aria familiare,
però, dietro le quinte,
spesso non è così rose e fiori.
Noi produciamo principalmente vino.
Per questo siamo anche
conosciuti in tutto il mondo,
ma da qualche anno ci siamo amplificati:
produciamo formaggi
e ortaggi, il mio reparto.
In effetti, il mio principale
pensiero quotidiano
rimane la carota.
Allora, la conosciamo tutti
questa carota, vero?
Un ortaggio banale all’apparenza
e comunque versatile.
L’abbiamo amato e apprezzato tutti
nella nostra vita.
Ma la carota la sappiamo distinguere.
Avete, però, mai preso in mano
i semi della carota?
Probabilmente chi ha un orto e chi
ha tentato di far crescere carote, sì.
I semi derivano da un fiore, ovviamente.
Chi ha mai visto un fiore di carota
di voi, alzi la mano.
Eccolo qua.
Ogni puntino bianco
che vedete diventa un seme
e con circa un cucchiaio di semi,
più o meno sono dieci, dodici grammi
possiamo produrre
centinaia di chili di carote,
come questa.
Ma prima di arrivare
alla carota vera e propria,
facciamo un passo indietro.
Perché dovete capire che produrre carote
non è così semplice.
La lavorazione del terreno
e la pianificazione,
tutto comincia a dicembre.
C’è chi pensa ai regali di Natale,
io penso alla pianificazione
dell’anno seguente.
Perciò quante carote voglio produrre,
quanti semi devo ordinare
della mia varietà preferita,
perché sappiate che ci sono
migliaia di varietà di carote.
Potrei parlarne per ore,
ma non è questo il punto oggi.
Vi faccio un esempio.
Carote viola.
All’interno sono arancioni.
Quest forse le vedete
un po’ in giro, ma sono rare.
Però, la cosa più importante da sapere
è che le vostre carote sono capricciose.
Vogliono germinare in un terreno perfetto,
perciò già la preparazione
del terreno prima di seminare
è un gesto quasi maniacale.
Sassi, infestanti.
Le infestanti sappiamo che ci sono sempre
e crescono molto meglio di
qualsiasi seme che mettete in terra.
È una lotta continua rincorrerle,
toglierle dai piedi.
Però, un altro fattore è l’acqua.
Ti dimentichi un’unica volta di irrigare
la tua cara carotina che sta germinando
sotto i tuoi piedi e paf!
Si offende, non c’è più
o fa altri scherzetti.
Tre mesi di attesa per raccoglierle,
per arrivare a questo risultato,
almeno tre mesi devono passare.
Il momento della raccolta
è una grande gioia,
ma anche un’ansia infinita.
Perché in quei tre mesi
forse qualcuno ha fatto festa,
i nostri cari amici del terreno:
topini, altri piccoli insetti
che traforano la carota,
queste cose le scopriamo
solo nel momento in cui raccogliamo.
Ma, soprattutto, cos’altro può succedere?
Questo:
le carote con mille piedi,
gambe attorcigliate, abbracciate.
Bellissime, divertentissime,
rendono la nostra raccolta
anche più variopinta,
perché tutte carote dritte, che noia!
Però, capite l’ansia.
Capite perché siamo nervosi
nel momento del raccolto.
Abbiamo fatto tutto per rendere
queste carote felici e poi...
scherzetto!
Ramificate.
Ma vi siete mai accorti che queste carote
non le trovate in giro
tranne nel vostro orto o nel mio
o in qualche altro orto di qualcuno.
Perché le carote ramificate
e di questi tipi,
che comunque ci fanno anche sorridere,
non le vediamo più al mercato?
Al supermercato sappiamo, ormai, niente:
carote dritte, grosse, da un chilo, fine.
Le carote storte con le gambe,
anche nei libri dei bambini,
io non le ho più viste.
Ma soprattutto, chi ha deciso
di discriminarle?
Chi ha deciso che queste carote,
pur essendo dello stesso gusto
di quelle dritte,
pur essendo cresciute nello stesso campo,
non sono interessanti?
Chi ha deciso che c’è uno standard
che ci dice la carota deve essere dritta,
grossa, perfetta, facile, da pelare
e soprattutto lì, pronta?
Così, proprio come questa.
Tra l’altro, senza ciuffo
la maggior parte delle volte.
Di fatto, se guardiamo i dati
che troviamo in giro,
solo in Svizzera, per esempio,
questo minuscolo Paese accanto a noi,
producono 60 mila tonnellate
di carote all’anno.
60.000 tonnellate, la Svizzera.
Bisogna avere una gran passione
per le carote, però è tanta la produzione.
Però, il 30% di questa produzione
viene scartata per difetti estetici:
graffi, ammaccature, rotture
durante lo smistamento.
Le macchine che vengono
calibrate allo standard
che vedete, infatti, sullo scaffale
del supermercato, non hanno pietà.
Fuori le carote che hanno
un minimo difetto di bellezza.
30% vuol dire che una gran parte
non viene utilizzata.
Almeno, non finisce
nel piatto di qualcuno.
Se vediamo la filiera alimentare
in generale abbiamo
il 45% della produzione ortofrutticola
che viene scartato.
Perciò, nessuno se la mangia,
forse qualche insetto, però non noi.
Quanta gente poteva mangiarci?
Lasciamo da parte questa tematica
molto complessa, ma arriviamo al dunque.
Perché voi dovreste sentirvi anche offesi.
Voi pensate di fare una scelta quando
andate a comprare le cose
al supermercato o al mercato contadino,
invece, qualcuno ha già fatto
la scelta per voi,
ha deciso che carota sarebbe quella giusta
o quale sarebbe la banana
o la fragola, qualsiasi cosa.
Sullo scaffale variopinto
sembra che abbiate il mondo,
invece è una piccola percentuale
di quello che vi sta a scegliere.
La soluzione?
Cambiar pagina, sta a voi.
Sta a voi allearvi con chi produce.
Ma, soprattutto, abbracciare
un contadino, un orticoltore, chiunque sia
che produce con passione,
che si prende cura della terra per voi,
perché è nostra scelta
con chi vogliamo dialogare e informarci.
È nostra scelta poter andare
al supermercato o al mercato contadino,
a trovare chi veramente
può anche condividere con voi
cosa è andato storto,
letteralmente, nell’orto,
soprattutto come queste carote
che si abbracciano in questa immagine.
L’abbracciare un agricoltore
nel senso proprio di partecipare,
essere nel sistema di produzione,
va ad accorciare la filiera,
perché voi avete modo di incontrarli
andando a uno spaccio aziendale,
per esempio.
Potete iscrivervi a un GAS,
i Gruppi d’Acquisto Solidale,
che si impegnano a portare
la connessione con i produttori
ai cittadini.
Ma potete andare anche oltre,
voi potete iscrivervi alla CSA,
Comunità che Supporta l’Agricoltura.
È un concetto abbastanza nuovo
e viene dal successo degli Stati Uniti
ma adesso si sta diffondendo
anche molto in Italia.
Semplicemente, il produttore,
io agricoltrice, io orticoltrice,
produco per voi membri
della mia comunità che mi supporta.
Ci incontriamo ogni settimana
al punto di ritiro definito
e facciamo una bella chiacchiera
su quello che finisce nella vostra borsa.
In questo modo, voi
potete attivamente chiedermi
perché ho troppe zucchine
e mai fragole,
perché le carote sono storte quest’anno
o perché sono tutte belle dritte?
Ovviamente, noi produttori ci impegniamo
a essere perfezionisti
e ci teniamo con il cuore
che la nostra produzione sia la più bella
e che sia tre volte più buona
di quello che trovate al supermercato.
Ma siete voi che potete attivamente
ritrovarvi a condividere emozioni con noi.
Noi che mettiamo il cuore
nella nostra quotidianità
per poterla condividere con voi
tramite il prodotto,
ma soprattutto parlandovi
e sentendovi nostri alleati.
E vi facciamo sentire
con la testa in terra il più possibile
e vogliamo che siate partecipi
della filiera.
Grazie.
(Applausi)